I'm here for the wild card games hey
guys
Tom Brady is here for the wild card get
lost oh hey old pal I will chop off my
penis to beat you his hand actually
looks pretty good are you sure you want
to go all in with him I can't believe
I'm not out with the pie team so drop
the kids even though we're not twenties
I want it all is this old man with your
party right now - pleasure to meet you
drew brees all right I got a full house
man we have an empty house except for
Boston Scott our whole team is wicked
banged up I raised you eight and no
lateral I'm not sure you know how to
play this game mr. Rogers did you play
before they invented the yellow first
down line oh you know that lines just on
TV I can see it
hey babe raps needs another drink no no
not again Taysom shut the car under
pressure I respectfully fold it gave it
everything I had I what not the Titans
here you go
Tommy Boy
hey what's up it's me Aaron Rodgers you
know the guy who's always making sweet
comebacks you should subscribe to
bleacher report so you can always come
back to watch more videos
ok Thank You Aaron that was great hey
see if we get someone young like Lamar
Jackson you know someone like fits our
demo a little better